[Music]
hi welcome to intense or insane and okay
yeah so for those of you who are joining
us from chess and psychology thank you
for staying this long for those of you
who are new welcome so I have a bunch of
studies prepared and some easy basic and
games and I liked it we should have a
chess on music so I'm just gonna review
some super basic concepts and then we'll
just jump into it all right whoops that
is not a super basic concept I was going
for
okay this one my stuff is a little hold
on sorry technical alright we are good
to go so do you think this end game is
winning draw lost
okay does everybody think his last white
if it was black to move black with just
so it is why to move
okay so generally the end games Queen
versus one pond and the pond on the
seventh track it is usually I don't know
why it says so it should be going this
way hold on
sorry all right let's look at this this
is more accurate okay sorry okay
so generally end games Queen versus one
pond when this pond is on H or F file
it's a draw because so in this position
if right now it's white to move white is
a stalemate can't move the pond can't
move the king
so if black could try to bring the Queen
closer but it's never gonna be enough
because the king is also very far if the
King was a slightly closer then yes this
would have been winning for black but
right now black there's no way for black
to try and progress so if this pond if
this Queen sorry if this pond was on a G
file in a pond versus a queen endgame
now this is winning can someone tell me
how
it is black to move
so this the simple way to think about it
is you want your king and your queen to
be as close to the whites king as
possible so how can you try to do that
too
without letting White's make it a queen
yeah that's that should be the idea so
yes that is the idea the simplest way to
do it is to go close to the king so the
king can't really get out and you're
also attacking the pawn and as soon as
King moves
regardless of which side it goes do you
give the check still attacking the pawn
now bring your king closer and then you
keep doing the same thing and eventually
your king will be close enough to try
and either eat the pawn or let's see for
example you just bring in your king
you just bring in your king and you just
eventually eat the pawn so now that we
know how to win against upon on G file
let's look at how to win when there's a
pawn on a file a or H the rook file so
the problem is you can't really bring
your king close because white King
doesn't have any room to go go to so
ideally in that situation that we were
looking at when there was the pawn and G
file you if this if there was another
file here that white King could go to
this is when you would bring your King
right but now you can't do that because
it's a stalemate so there's no way for
you to try and bring your king closer
without either still it or just trying
to bring the king now there's a queen so
you simply can't bring your chin closer
now if the if the King was a slightly
closer you could actually try to bring
win this game because now you bring your
Queen as close as possible now you go
with the king
now the thing is in these specific
situations when both King and the Queen
are like in the L positions with the
King with the opposite colored King is
making a queen
King bee six wins because there is no
way that Wyatt can avoid it mate so this
these are some of the ideas to keep in
mind when you're looking at Queen and
games and let's look at what if the pawn
was on F line so if the pawn was on the
bishops file the problem is actually let
me ask first does anybody want to take a
shot that's what the problem is
yeah that the problem that black can't
win it's a draw
yeah because when you would bring
remember how ideally you wanted to bring
your queen closer when the pawn was on
like key file and the problem is yes if
black work if whites were to bring the
King under the pawn again now you can
bring your king closer but the trick is
that after something like check over
here
black simply puts the King in the corner
and you can't take the pawn because it's
still mate
so like these are the the little stuff
to remember when you're doing Queen
Queen versus pawn and games and all
right without further ado we did our
fundamental parts let's jump into the
practical part so oops so we talked
about some ideas about putting the King
in the corner that like L like having
both of your king and queen on L
position to your opponent's king to try
and mate Wow
I have no idea anyways so try to think
how can you put the King in the corner
it was hitting the windows
oh it's why to move so usually if that
one up there says one dot it's white if
it's three dots then it's black
yes
where
I like that idea the king can only go to
a tree right because if King a4 just
Queen gives another check on a file and
picks up the Queen so what now
so what are the move that you're trying
to achieve what is the ideal setup that
you're trying to achieve
I like that idea I think when a five
might be more accurate because it kind
of forces the king to go to beat you but
so now what so you kind of want to keep
the king in the corner so most likely or
next one is also going to be a check
with the Queen to force and if King a to
yeah yeah so it's the same I didn't we
were talking about that ideally you want
to have that King cornered and I wish I
could like flip the board but I don't
think I can but if you look at it as if
hypothetically if this were actually
instead of a 1 square this like the pawn
could go up like this if after King C 2
I might make it too complicated I don't
want to confuse you but so the idea is
that if this pawn were here and made a
queen and your King was on c3 you were
just to play King seats you the same
thing I was telling you about having
your king and queen in like Knight was
in the L and or like the nice position
to your opponent's king so that's as
soon as they make the Queen you bring
the King to seat you take away these
square for Queen no more check and now
you have different kinds of mate so it's
the same idea might be a little hard to
picture it when there is actual Queen in
the board instead of the pawn becoming
the queen but yeah so does it make sense
for everybody I hope I didn't confuse
you what if King goes to c1
yeah so simple mate all right perfect
okay so this is parlance game but it's
not gonna stay pond game it's gonna
Queens are gonna come in so it's black
to move but I kind of has to push the
punt right that doesn't it's not even a
question at this point so try to think
and calculate how can white win and or
if white is when you well technically up
there it sails win so I can't really
trick you with that but so yeah try to
calculate and it does with Queen Anne's
games like Queen versus quick-like
simply does Queen versus Queen there's
not that many ideas to keep track of
that's the idea that we looked at in the
previous game at previous puzzle it's
pretty much the main want to look out
for
yeah but yeah of course but I was trying
to get you to actually find the mate
before we set it on the board or find
the one or one way to think in pun and
games is instead of thinking oh if I
play a four he will put h4 and do like
one by one you can think how many moves
do I need so you can tink yeah so you
can simply think I need one two three
four five to make a queen and give a
check just whoops this is in the same
diagonal I mean just and black needs one
two three four views so when I make mine
so pretty much you you have five holes
to make a queen black as foremost but
it's your move so as soon as black makes
the Queen you are also going to make a
queen so instead of thinking about a 4h
or a 5h string you could just count it
as many days many moves my opponent has
this many moves
so do we all have the clear picture of
black has a queen on each one White has
a queen on a eight giving a check
everybody good on that okay cool so in
that position the king can only go to
places G 1 and H 2 right so try to think
how or if you can actually achieve that
dream of kings
that's like LPL idea like the Double L
idea how can you achieve that
it matters which direction the King
moves correct
yeah I shouldn't
basically the idea is that you can't
have to come up with some way to bring
the Queen close enough so the king can't
scape and then you would just bring your
king in front of the opponent's king
it's just you have to be careful how you
get there
I could I could move the pieces and we
could have the Queen setup if you would
prefer okay
so
okay so we we were at this position now
if the King goes to g1 how do you get to
that dream position
be careful cuz the Queen G 2 blocks and
gives a check
yeah I also think my between a one would
work king h2 queen like 'if I've
probably that should also work let's see
Queen I think this also should be good
enough the only problem I mean not
really problem if you go here I can just
take c7 Queen a one might be just a
little faster because now you get to
bring the Queen closer and closer and
now the king of two and win right cool
okay this is a little too theoretical
but the idea is that you simply want to
trap the night and it is possible so we
could just go over it or we you could
take a minute or two and try to find it
on your own and then we'll go over it
one tiny piece of advice that in in
Reverse this night it is a good idea to
have the rook in this type of positions
like because if the rook is one square
away from this like diagonal wise does
it make sense because it's kind of
paralyzing the knight see the knight
can't go to F D to D 45 and g5 because
of this rook
so it is a good idea to have it away
like the one like one away from the in
the same diagonal but just one square
away yeah
ideally yeah that's that's the idea you
would want to come and pick up the
nights with the king
you could try and push the night further
back or and more in the corner
Kingdom
let's see you said King be five I don't
think it's wrong but I kind of it kind
of feels a little off he would prefer to
have the King come closer and I
understand that the King V five you're
trying to tie up the other Kings hands a
little but what about a move such as
Rick at five
now if tonight goes to d2 try to apply
the same logic rook in the same diagonal
just like one square way
when the night is an f3 you're Brooke on
d5 was very strong right what's kind of
tying the Knights hands so what about
that a night on teach you how can you
try and tie the nice hand up
yeah
so the idea is simple after looking for
you just want to bring your king in with
probably King before King c3 something
like that so if something like King
Knight b3 just came before now the night
is still stuck and now the night wants
to jump to like d3 or issue just bring
the King to c4 if 92 again rook g4 so
you still keep those critical squares
and now you just come and pick up the
night yeah
and F here instead of check King goes to
a6 you still come cut the king and you
wanna still clicking c3 you're still
cutting the the night and now you pick
it up
did it make sense I feel like you have
in in your game if you haven't heard
about this like idea of like where the
rook should be it's kind of hard to
think about it so hopefully next time
something like this happens you know
what to do and kinda yeah yeah like I
did I I don't even remember from where
but he was like so many years ago 20
yeah there's not like it says it's for
1600 so I hope that's true but no for me
like maybe about everything it was
twenty twelve thirteen fourteen one of
those tears that I was trying to figure
out more puzzles to do at home I ended
up put these and they're like twenty-six
thousand of them yeah I never finished
it so yeah so I tried to collect the
ones that seem more relevant and doable
okay it's white to move this one should
be easy peasy
the king is already in the corner you
just need to bring more reinforcements
to meet it
thank you okay this one it does say draw
so let's respect that but be careful
because here you are if it's black tail
black is picking up your drug and also
kind of giving you a checkmate so you
kind of have to come up with something a
little sneaky to block off the mate and
not give up the rook
you won't be giving it for free I mean
you won't be losing after giving it up
if that makes sense
oh yeah
all right five
this yeah after take check and pick the
truck up yeah little tricky right you
might have a Sheree I mean you might
actually like see that in the game and
resign and yeah why to move pretty easy
think about checks and mates
yeah so it's just mother mate right yep
yeah after saying something hard makes
it kind of nice to see easy alright this
is also white to move it is a draw and
white spawns are going down with black
spawns coming this way good luck
yeah
so I just want to bring in the king all
right
and if I move the bishop still King c7
should do it right now if you push push
if Queen Queen already draw if take and
then clean we know that these all draw
so oh a little tricky thing if you play
King a eight your opponent's could bring
in the King like this so don't do that
and then we'll get to that's anywhere
actually but
so yeah be careful when there's a chance
for that if black if your opponents
could bring the king to take care of
still mates be careful about that and so
just go to the other way and now you
want to make a queen Yin so the Queen
has to move and now you bring in the
king so the king is too far this is a
draw next one any questions cool not
exactly an end game but it's pretty cool
want to do it I don't know what is it
doing here
but it's a pretty cool one you should be
able to do it right
it was probably creative
most likely probably also because I said
it's pretty cool alright so we want to
take this I think right and now what
finally most accurate win
you do have to move the night but if 96
King comes to age 7 and then rook g7
King age 6 then you have maybe Bishop c1
yeah I like that I was thinking about
Knight takes f7 I think that should also
be because if night have seven yeah I
mean yeah or if King either once made
King takes rook g7 King year 7 rock g7
either one is made so like 96 also
should be winning but I mean I can keep
going and yeah it's not the most clean
win you've seen in your life but it's
still pretty cool all right
why to move and the pawn is becoming a
queen for flack
I'm gonna give you one tip if you're
thinking about something kind of like
straightforward don't think about how to
know your opponent like I mean make sure
the king is kind of stuck somewhere
can't move
all right dearly because if it's white
if it was black to move all right let's
say white does something and when you go
try to hunt down this pond the king is
just in time - yeah to get under here
and it this will be a draw right because
now your king is the one that's kind of
whoops that's kind of stuck and this is
a stalemate so instead of having your
your king is stuck try to have your
opponent's king stuck yeah exactly
oh yeah so you have it just telling them
you want to give a check to see - but
then check to see - I mean you kind of
only have one good idea to win in this
position Roxy - you could come back to
it like you could just come back to this
position but do you want more time we're
doing let's just tell it I gotta give
more sir all right so they move to do is
Rick a 1 so the idea is simply you just
want to keep the king over here and now
you have to play g5 yeah and even though
black manages to make a queen it's not
enough
next one okay it is white to move should
be easy again see we have cars we have
easy
yep
yeah okay and that's how we do it all
right why still move find me the draw
most likely it's gonna be stalemate
right
so what some of your thinking about
what
but the pond is
King F - I think the problem is rookie -
and if take Queen if King comes down
check and then Queen
so think about checks first
yeah and the King has to come to GTA so
now how they try to do stalemate yeah
matric right everyone good cool and yeah
this is dry oops what I mean black if
black moves you just keep hunting down
the rook let's go back so like if not
take Japan doesn't matter where the
roukoz you just keep following it cool
whoops that is not what I meant to do
okay
now why to move
- - cool if King g3
mm-hmm yeah and that's about it I do
think that if King G for this is yeah
you could keep trying to give check and
yeah this is this should be draw because
the King can't come here because it will
cave - so cool
whoops oh we do have a cool game okay
all right disposition
how would you proceed welp I will go a
little bit farther now it's black to
move how do you continue just the hence
it is tactics
strategic sacrifices
stuff like that
nice tree
yeah yeah yeah that is the correct move
but just why do you say that just as I
said sacrifice yeah well I am I didn't
see it the first time I was thinking
about it it's like I think it would have
been kind of easier to see it if the
Panos are still on h3 so you were like
thinking oh it takes but this is kind of
a very interesting idea because so black
can't just tried to will technically
black hand try to just bring in the King
and then just go now just play something
like piece of history but the problem is
if you were to play something like a
tree you can't really keep making
progress and even though it is very
interesting and you could try to like
keep pushing and then try to like bring
the King here why it still has to find
the most accurate moves it's not that
easy it's like what just just doesn't
have a draw but I move such as Bishop h3
is way more cool and also after white
takes now you don't have that kind of
this bishop on the way so you can try to
bring in the King but so what do you
want to do now and just because I said
King it doesn't mean it's King Fi
it could be but
yeah I remember when I was looking at
this game like before the sacrifice I
kind of wish that my pawn was a little
bit more advanced and then I did the
sacrifice and then I thought to myself
that if the pawn was advanced it also
meant that the White King would be more
to central yeah more active more
centralized so probably it wouldn't have
been as easy but right now after King
after the King gets to e4 just in time
and next move you might want to push for
d4 like if Bishop takes f6 you might
want to simply play d4 and it's kind of
blocking its blocking upon the bishop
coming back and now you were going to
play a treat so bishop has to come and
cut it and now King goes to d3 King
comes to c4 you want to keep your pawns
as long as possible
cutting the king now it's time to keep
pushing for a tree don't make these kind
of mistakes and end up in a draw because
the bishop comes to d4 just don't don't
don't blunder always find the clay and
the most clean the one that doesn't give
your opponent as much chance so a tree
is that move and d2 now it wins and so
the point is in this position and the
initial position when black sheriff
decided to sacrifice a bishop I think
for him it was more like what's that
what's the one move that kind of annoys
my opponent the most or like messes the
team most psychologically and also
doesn't give him any chance to
to try to strike back because something
move like a tree is such a natural
nice-looking move and you have your pawn
advanced to the extent that it can and
now you could try to even like bring
your king from the other side
whoops and it looks very logical but
your White has a clear path White has a
very clear idea to just keep the king in
the center and just don't let the pawns
be Queens but in this situation why it
doesn't have that clear idea anymore
now the King now white kind of just
psychologically a little that it's not
as easy that's what I'm trying to say
and just don't try to make your
opponent's life easy just try to keep
them on their toes I guess so yeah yeah
that's actually something that I thought
about and if the King comes up you could
just either push with the king and then
take the pawn and still bring your king
to the center or you could just take the
pawn here and bring your chain to the
center which I would kind of recommend
for not making your opponent's life easy
and bringing your King in first mm-hmm
well still the point is about getting
the King to the center so like even if
you would play something like King III
and just want to this one well it
doesn't really matter I still get my
King to the center this Bishop doesn't
really play any role in the game it
wasn't it was kind of never about the
bishop it was more about in this in this
position if this bishop wasn't here King
was cooking would go to f-5e for yeah
something yeah
pretty much but Bishop on h3 has more
psychological effects also is attacking
g2 because if you were to simply play
Bishop g4 the King could come to f2 and
then the King could come to e3 but in
this situation King III yeah yeah well
this one this one was one of my favorite
ones and I think it's a very cool way to
and today's lecture I hope you enjoyed
it and yeah games are pretty fun just
know some basic rules and keep your
pieces active
[Music]
you